All right.
Now, we
are moments away from a high stakes,
one on one meeting in Moscow
between Russian
President Putin
and Chinese President Xi
as Xi arrived in Moscow
for the state visit just a few hours ago.
Beijing, of course,
framing this trip
as more of a peacemaking mission
amidst the war in Ukraine.
It comes
just after the International
Criminal Court
issued an arrest warrant
for Vladimir Putin,
essentially charging him
with the abduction of children
from Ukraine.
Joining us now to discuss
what those charges could actually mean
is Leila
set out as a professor
at Washington
University in Saint Louis School of Law
and one of the world's
foremost authorities
when it comes
to international criminal law.
It's good
to have you with us this morning.
So when these charges broke,
there was a lot of talk
about how they are largely symbolic
since the reality of Putin traveling
to a country.
Right, an ICC country
where he could potentially be arrested
seems slim.
Why do you think
the charges were filed now?
Well, the
charges are filed
because Ukraine
referred the case to the court
and actually 41 states
joined the referral to the court.
Ukraine asked the ICC to investigate,
as did 41 members of the court
states parties, if you like.
And that means that the prosecutor
has an obligation to investigate.
And the prosecutor
has to follow the facts and the law
and the facts,
as we've seen on our television screens.
Thanks so much to CNN
for your great reporting, by the way.
Erica.
The facts really drive
this case and the facts are shocking
and their illumination of war crimes.
And so the prosecutor
really has no obligation
but to file charges.
We have really seen
this concerted effort.
I mean, I was even meeting
with Polish officials
just about a year ago
talking about their efforts
to work to help document
potential war crimes.
What more do you see could be coming?
I think this is the tip of the iceberg.
I think it's a brilliant strategy
on the part of the prosecutor to charge
both Vladimir Putin
and his commissioner
for children's rights
in this case,
because there are two war crimes
that have been charged.
They're relatively obvious.
Russia's essentially admitted
to what happened.
Vladimir Putin
and his minister have stated
that they engaged in this conduct.
And so it's really obvious.
And it's also a
particularly heinous offense.
These are actually grave breaches
of the Geneva Conventions
and Russia is a party
to the Geneva Conventions.
So Russia knows exactly
that these are not okay.
The transfer
and deportation of children
during war is unlawful.
So I think these are the tip
of the iceberg.
I think we're going to see a lot more
charges relating
probably to crimes against humanity,
probably to the
aerial bombardment campaign
and other attacks on civilians
and civilian infrastructure.
So while you anticipate more charges,
what do you think the outcome of
some of those charges will be?
Because correct me if I'm wrong,
but these ICC charges
Putin, for example, can't be
tried in absentia, correct?
That's absolutely right, Erica.
And, of course,
we know that international justice
always has to play the long game.
Many times
we found ourselves in this situation
before with respect
to Slobodan Milosevic,
with respect to Charles Taylor,
with respect
to Ratko Mladic,
we've had to wait a long time
to get our defendants in the dock.
That said, as a permanent court,
the International Criminal Court
can wait.
There's no statute of limitations.
And it makes it much more difficult
both for President Putin
and for his commissioner
to travel abroad
to conduct their business
and subjecting them potentially
to crippling sanctions
at a personal level,
as well as because of their state conduct
everywhere they go.
Really quickly before I let you go.
Do you see these both these charges
and the potential for additional charges
in any way influencing the behavior
or the orders given to Russian troops?
So I don't see President Putin himself
all of a sudden having a change of heart
and saying, you know,
this is a really bad idea.
We shouldn't
we shouldn't be violating
international law.
What I suspect, though,
is that others under his command,
soldiers in the field,
when asked to do things
that are
manifestly unlawful,
that are clearly breaches
of international law,
not just in the ICC statute,
but in all the treaties
that Russia is a party
to Russia
as a party,
to the genocide convention,
to the Geneva Conventions.
I think a lot of the people
in Russia,
once they learn about these things,
are going to have second thoughts
about this war.
And we understand from the reporting
that's now ongoing
that that's already happening.
Ladies,
that really appreciate your insight
this morning. Thank you.